foreign
because first of all this vehicle was
sixty two thousand dollars I did it for
60 months instead of 72 and I went zero
down just didn't want to put any money
down because it's just it doesn't make
any sense to me you put how much money
do you save if you put more money down
so basically every thousand dollars that
you put down is about twenty dollars so
it would take five grand for me to lower
my monthly payment by a hundred dollars
so in thirteen hundred versus twelve
hundred yeah same thing you know take
you what is that 60 months to get your
money back or 50 months oh yeah
it'd take way too long
wow
Rachel some people's cornbread just
ain't done in the middle you know they
just didn't didn't fully bake in the
oven so this is let me recap what this
guy just said
he bought a vehicle that was sixty two
thousand dollars MSRP
with zero down thirteen hundred bucks a
month for 60 months which if you're
doing the math at home is seventy eight
thousand dollars for a vehicle that was
worth sixty two thousand dollars before
he drove it off the lot and that it's
yeah it's appreciated already and so his
logic though has nothing to do with the
interest paid he's going why would I put
more down it's only going to lower the
payment by 100 bucks what's the
difference between 1200 and 1300
and this is why we're broke it's not in
we can't keep blaming inflation and eggs
at some point we have to look in the
mirror and go stop being an idiot stop
buying 62 000 cars and paying 78 000 for
them while making fifty thousand and
then going oh I wish Biden would really
fix it and the taxes and the Egg prices
are out of control Rachel I'm going full
King of the Hill at this point oh I love
it George well for me car payment car
loans car payments it's like it's it's
the it's my worst type of day if we had
a rate debt for me it's the most
annoying you know student loans you get
a degree it's stupid that's probably
second like I mean like sure uh credit
cards people are like we'll paid off
whatever so if we rate the debt car
loans for me it's the it's the dumbest
and it's the one you can justify the
most but but mathematically speaking
when you just look at your finances it
is it's the it's the dumbest thing that
you can do with your money it really is
because you're borrowing money paying
interest on something that's going down
in value it's not an asset and it's for
what
I'm being serious like I'm like this is
unbelievable like it's it's one thing
when we talk to people and they're in
credit card debt because they're behind
on their bills and they're trying to let
you know what I mean like and you're and
you're kind of talking through this
needs versus wants and uh you know we
get those calls you know all the time
but I'm like but a car payment it's it's
literally two for sixty two thousand
dollars to look a certain way and feel a
certain way it's an ego thing the book
the psychology of money have you read it
oh no Delaney told me so good I've heard
so things but I love what he said in
there he said really the re the reason
people don't save like it it's it's your
ego
and so if this guy's ego was out of the
way and drove a great Honda Civic now
and didn't have that car payment
he would be able to save
that what thirteen hundred dollars a
month but instead and invest it but it's
going into a not an asset it's again
because it goes down in value it's not
even like two thousand dollar car is now
worth fifty and then 40. I mean it's
just and again it's a for a car to get
to point A to point B and I'm not mad at
cars we like cars sure uh so it's not
that but it's it's the way we our
mindsets around it and financially how
it plays out it just becomes such a huge
burden on on families and
uh it's it's not wise
come on dude like we have such a culture
of debt that we're so obsessed with debt
that the logic doesn't go to hey how
much am I paying an interest instead it
goes well my payments actually you know
it's 100 bucks more but what's the point
of putting more money down just save 100
bucks on my payment right we're still
thinking in such a stupid lens of what's
the payment can I afford the payment
you're not even looking at the entire
mathematical equation and for getting
interest in all of it yeah well here's
where that short-term thinking leads us
Rachel okay the CBS News article
millions of Americans nearing retirement
age with no savings so here's a real sad
story of a woman who's juggling two jobs
she's 66 years old sometimes working up
to 11 hours a day hoping wishing to be
retired playing piano enjoying her life
but she has no savings or 401K not even
enough to cover an emergency she sold
her home and bought a smaller one with
two other women
at 66 yeah yeah this is really sad and
here's the stats the U.S Census Bureau
data shows that 50 of women and 47 of
men between 55 and 66 years old have no
retirement savings half
zilch that's pretty wild that if you
were to quiz me if we did a pop quiz I
wouldn't think it was that high I didn't
think it was that high oh
yeah and she said I have a live for now
philosophy I guess
you think
I mean it's shocking to me that people
wake up at 66 and go I should probably
do something about that retirement thing
huh instead of using time while we have
it on this our precious time on earth
right right to retire with dignity and
have a great life and so this is really
really sad according to AARP
um you know experts say it's not too
late to make a plan which means we're
continuing to work we're lowering cost
of living saving when you can delaying
Social Security benefits until 70 to get
the largest check possible
the problem is people can't delay those
Social Security checks because they need
them now yeah they have because they're
so broke
and so this is just a I think the
situation is only going to get worse
if America doesn't wake up
oh my gosh yeah so it's just and again
regardless of what age you are we are in
the the business of hope to be like you
can do something different about your
situation again regardless of your age
but when you have time on your side so
young people out there we're talking to
it is it's so important to look at the
future and the problem is George like we
want everything right now we want our
life to feel good we want to we want to
do what we want and saying no to what we
want in the moment is not it's not
popular and people you know it's so easy
just to fall into that instant
gratification and again we're not saying
that you can't have a life and you can't
enjoy your life and enjoy your money but
it has to be in a level of a proper
order and for it to make sense and the
problem is is that people there's not a
plan there's not a level of
intentionality and it's just living
paycheck to paycheck and you just go
through your life and then you wake up
at 66 and you're thinking oh my gosh I
have nothing to say so we just don't
want that for you the truth is it's not
that hard to be a millionaire you just
need to put a little bit away
consistently over a long period of time
so the math isn't that hard it's the
emotion it's the behavior it's the
habits and so I'm plugging in this guy's
1300 car payment into our investment
calculator 30 years old if you started
with zero dollars and you invested that
thirteen hundred dollar car payment into
the stock market into a good index fund
a mutual fund at 65 you would have 3.8
million dollars is that if you invested
every month if you invest 1300 bucks
every month which this guy people like
this will always have a car yeah yeah
for sure 100 of a big car payment and
he'd have close to four million dollars
we have close to four million yep
instead he could be like this poor woman
and that's it 66 for me where I'm like
you're choosing to to drive a car or
have four million dollars like that's
that's it but he's out here peddling his
wealth hacks the ego
yes like it's I mean seriously that's
that's what happens any bro bragging
about his 62 000 car was zero down and
here's what's funny too I'll quote the
same book because he talked about how he
was a the author was a valet in DC
and he said he would park I mean insane
cars like you know Lamborghinis I mean
just like Porsche all the all the
amazing cars and he said what's funny
about being a valet and for majority of
people out there when you see an awesome
car
you look at the car and you think that's
a cool car could I ever drive that car
you start imagining yourself in that car
what do I need to do to drive that car
you're not looking at the actual driver
and looking at the looking at the the
man or the woman and thinking oh I
wonder what what that guy oh and you
start you know wondering about the
driver no you're looking at the car so
it's even like we kind of puff up
ourselves of like oh I'm gonna drive a
cool car because people are going to
think I'm successful they're really not
even looking at you they're looking at
the car so like and the crazy part is
this whole thing I've got a friend who's
got a really expensive car hundreds of
thousands of dollars afraid to drive it
wouldn't you be oh man imagine driving
your house around worrying you're gonna
get a scratch on the thing you're
parking 19 miles away so that no someone
doesn't dig your door I know we weren't
meant to lose like this Mo Money Mo
Problems amen
and I'd rather have more money in the
bank than in stuff going down in value
let's make good choices America this is
the Ramsay show
foreign